[Music]
ashley's in jacksonville florida hey
ashley what's up
hi guys um thank you so much for taking
my call um i just have a quick question
trying to figure out if we bought too
much house in 2020
um my husband and i did baby got to baby
step six in 2018 and 2019 paying off our
debt um and paying off about 30 of our
house
and then decided we wanted to find a
better home home for family somewhere
that we could be as intentional as we
were but actually enjoy where we were
living
but we got back into debt doing it which
is terrible please don't yell at me
um we got about 35 000 into debt um and
we just paid that off last month so we
are happily in baby step three um
but now that we're moving towards baby
step four and the percentages of like
how much my house payment is obviously
gonna go it's to be more of my income
since i'm going to be putting 15 into
investment and i'm just trying to figure
out
if we bought too much house
well the investment does not affect your
housing formula
15 going into investments doesn't affect
that what's your gross pay or your your
net pay not counting what goes into 401k
not counting what goes into health
insurance but just net of taxes
net of taxes what's your household take
home pay
um and that's
sorry that's after taxes i'm not great
with the lingo after taxes
what's your yeah after taxes i i don't
know the annual income but it's about 8
000 a month
okay and how much is your house payment
um 21.62
it's like a fourth i mean what's the
problem it's almost the fourth i wasn't
sure if you know because we're about to
get to baby step four and i was worried
once the 15
um started coming out obviously that
dramatically changes how much we could
be putting towards the house and our
biggest goal is kind of getting that
thing paid off so well you're gonna put
15 at baby step four of your income
towards retirement but that does not
affect the
calculation of your house payment being
25 of your take-home pay because your
take-home pay is not what comes out
take-home pay means after taxes
and so
so you're making a hundred thousand so
you're probably making a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars a year gross
does that sound about right yeah okay
yeah that sounds great yeah and so
you're fine on this there's nothing
wrong here you're going to put 15 away
and then you're going to have to begin
to chip away at the mortgage beyond that
as you work through baby steps five and
six kids college and anything extra you
can find you put on the house but your
house payment is not going to keep you
from putting 15 down or 15 into
retirement it's it's just not you're not
house poor not even close
so i think what you did was you uh
took a step up and it's a bigger payment
than you're emotionally used to and it
just smacked you around a little bit
which is not a bad thing
uh that you that you recognized it
because the the people that are scary
are the ones that don't realize
that there was a an emotional shift here
and ouch you can get that sneak up on
you and get you